[Music]
hello everyone hello
charles marie hello jean françois
welcome to talk to you the cloud
today we are on episode 3
out of 5 of a series of five episodes that
wants to explain
how to develop  an internet
of things project with google the
platform and today we are going to talk
about data flow my name is jean françois
mas crazy i am a consultant claude
in the professional services
organization entity of google cloud and i am
charles  marie desjardins
client engineers also for govt etc la
charlerie can you
explain to us what dataflow is great
pleasure then dataflow is a service
completely managed by google which will
make it possible to transform and enrich
a given heap whatsoever  in streaming or
in match I see then then
can you show us how it works
well listened with pleasure
as you see it on the
reference architecture to data flow tools  and in
our example mainly used
to transport data between
pop seube and bikkuri but we could
imagine going much further to
do aggregation or other pre-processing
and enrich this collected aliotti data
before getting to the heart of the
matter I would like  first of all mentioned
the dataflow templates they are
predefined models to do a
certain number of relatively
simple operations without having to code
anything and they are accessible directly
from the gcp console moreover it is
quite possible  to define its
own template in order to deploy
custom models very quickly thereafter
here I will show you the deployment
of a model pops bob verbe cauet it is
enough for me to specify the name of my job
the topic pop seube on which one awaits
the  messages the bikkuri table to
which you want to direct your
messages as well as a location where data
flow will write temporary files  res
and here we go once dataflow
has fully deployed this model everything
will pass here open and the data will
flow automatically from pop seube
verb hickory it's not more complicated
than that now let's move on to some
code
as you may know  -être cloud data
flow is based on a
unified programming model which
natively integrates a certain number of
connectors with gcp services like
pop seube or cloud storage or bikkuri
for example as you have just seen
with the template dataflows will therefore
allow us  to build a
data processing pipeline you see it here
we must first define this
pipeline as well as these
execution parameters that we will be able to
configure either directly in
the code or via the command line
is  here you also see
what one of these famous collector looks like
this one is for advertising we find here the
topic to configure on which we will
come and listen to my  sages what is
nice is that the connector itself
will take care of setting up the
subscription to this topic
it saves us work it is
also important to note that
dataflow can work in batch or in
streaming which amounts to  say that the
sources are either finite when we talk
about files for example or
virtually infinite as for people
because events can happen at
any time and despite everything these two
modes will be able to be processed with
the same pipeline with only a
few minor modifications in
particular  at the source level,
it is also the bringing together of these two
worlds that will contribute to
bringing value to data flow now
that we have implemented the data management part
we will be able to do a very
large number of things at high  level
this will materialize by
the aggregation of measures, for example
information filtering or joins
on various data sources
imagine that we  d a fleet of taxis
to manage this fleet reports from time to
time information on their
positions their income
the number of people on board and it is
this type of transformation will
allow us to collect information
on traffic
by aggregating for example the
position data of taxis by geographical area
or so to know in real time their
revenues generated by the entire
fleet or even
imagine locating taxis
not carrying passengers is
to inform customers come
applications the estimated time of  expectations
if he commits a race
we will go over a little code here
in our example this script will
make it possible to find the number of taxis
by geographical area of about 500 meter
sideways this
ill for example give the possi
ility of knowing  what are the
areas best covered at the moment
by taxis in order perhaps to
regulate traffic
we find here the creation of the pipe line as
well as the connector  pub and this is
where it starts to get interesting
the information that we receive by the
connector is issued regularly
pays taxi and contains a
race identifier a latitude longitude for the
position and other information such as
the number of passengers at  edge the
first step will consist in defining
a processing window which is a
necessary step when dealing
with
streaming data indeed these data are virtually
infinite because they arrive
as taxis send them on  the
field and it is therefore necessary to
define its calculation windows in order to be
able to apply the different
algorithms without having to wait
indefinitely for the footage where it dominates as
well as the trigger or trigger
are more advanced notions on
which I think it would be necessary
unfortunately, to come back to a
future video on the definition of the
window selected here we
typically see that the type of window  and
fixed with a duration of one second
which means that we will apply the
calculation to all the data that arrived
during the last second
it is certainly not
the most precise thing but I think that
for  a visualization dashboard that
should be enough
that obviously depends on the skies here we
consider that taxis send a
message per second is that the accuracy
of the result is not key in data flow
everything is always a question of
balance between the  precision of the data
and the latency of the 'pipeline' and the price
it will be necessary to adapt and depending on
what we want to do a pipeline
allowing to calculate once a month
the customer invoices according to their
consumption for example will
require  be precise whereas if we
just want to show an estimate
of today's consumption, we
will be a little less careful about
the accuracy of giving it, but we will
want real-time information
go back to code one  e once the time window is
defined here we will aggregate the
information received by
geographical area in the function that
we will find at the top we associate a
zone identifier with the messages received
by taxi
and we return this list in
key value form therefore alone  geographical
message
the next step here will simply be
to use a pre-existing function
in data flow which is to count the
number of elements having the same key is
therefore in our case the number of
messages associated with the same geographical area
let's now move on to this  that we do with
all this data generated here in the same
way that we had a good number of
connectors included in data we need for
the collection or management of data
we also have some to save
the data elsewhere for example to write
the results  in files on
google storage return messages
in pop seube or save all that
in big wave here in our
example it is assumed that you  tre
visualization dashboard is also
connected to people but on a
different topic which explains why
our destination defines here is
another topic people the lines that we
see there allow to properly format the
data before sending it back in this
topic
in our  pebble ti we will send the
deal is rather in a big wave table
which will allow to analyze it in more
detail later this is what we
find here
it is indeed possible to send a deal
to several
different destinations  with the same 'pipeline' they
are not necessarily linear
it is also possible to have
several data sources to
allow aggregation etc.
we can therefore imagine complex 'pipelines'
with several
input sources and several destinations  as an
output I think to conclude it
may be worth mentioning that
the clubs work which can
run for example upon receipt
of an open storage file pe  can
be used to trigger if
desired
a temple and data flow that we will have
previously imploded and which I
spoke to you about earlier
suddenly upon receipt of a csv for
example on gcs we will be able to if
desired  by automating the processing in
batch mode via dataflow then chars
the stop is what I need a
multitude of servers to run
dataflow then what is great is
that finally the service is
completely managed by google which
amounts to  say that everything is or at the
heart and provisioned and
configured completely automatically
and if I want to run my code
on another infrastructure that is
also possible what to
know is that data flow is in fact
a runner 2  apajh grimm apajh bim and
therefore was open source and by google
some time ago now and
therefore has other runner 2 available in
particular for apache park apache flink
and others which amounts to saying that you
can do  your was a job elsewhere if
you want okay and when I hear the
internet of things often I
also think of predictive maintenance scenarios
so I wonder can we
use machine learning models
from the ata  flow then
absolutely we can use the models in
particular generated via cloud ml which is
therefore our service completely
automatic learning manager and therefore
soyuz skies of predictive maintenance
is entirely possible via data
flow and what is to know  that
you are security then security side the
same it will be completely managed at
the creation of the project a certain number
of service accounts will be created
provisioned which will make it possible to
secure the various accesses of the
'pipeline' to the various resources of
the platform  in particular where the cloud
storage or big one thank you charles-marie
for all these explanations for all
the demonstrations town hall side great
pleasure and for this  ux who wish to
deepen do not hesitate to consult the
description of this video you will
find there resources to
deepen and in particular also an
incredible inference in French on this
know that the first the next
episode of the series will be related to big
wave thank you to you
See you soon
[Music]